Abraham a 17 ans ses parents comme ceux
de la future mariée son vendeur
ambulance et de saunion dans la cuisine
vous les mettez tout en haut ok cela
fait un an qu'ils économisent pour payer
ses noces elles ont coûté 30000 euros
pour un gitan même pauvre un mariage
doit être spectaculaire même s'ils ont
investi une grande partie de leurs
économies ils n'ont pas pu s'offrir de
traiteurs alors c'est toute la famille
qui se met au fourneau
de grosses quantités sont à prévoir car
c'est les gitans il n'y a pas
d'habitation tout le monde peut venir à
la fête
merci d'être là mon frérot ça c'est mon
frère ça mon frérot d'amour
t'inquiète pas c'est très sympa moi je
serai pas là et tu pourras kiffer
on va revoir des images de ce reportage
là la première chose qui a choqué et
téléspectateurs c'est quand on découvre
les deux jeunes mariés parce qu'il
s'agit en réalité de deux très jeunes
mariés regardez
elle s'appelle derea elle n'a que 15 ans
elle est encore au collège c'est
adolescente qui trace sa famille ce soir
les deux adolescents se connaissent
depuis qu'ils sont nés
Abraham a demandé des réa en mariage il
y a un an elle avait alors 14 ans
alors est-ce que est-ce que ça choque
quelqu'un ici oui
je sais que les gitans se marient entre
14 et 16 ans souvent là c'est 15 ans
mais est-ce qu'à 15 ans on a son libre
arbitre est-ce que ce ne sont pas les
familles qui vont orienter le mariage
moi ça ça me perturbe grandement je vous
le dis sincèrement alors moi je te dis
déjà souvent choqué mais avant je vais
te dire ça on a pris pareil un extrait
où ça c'est fini on est en 2023 plus
personne se marie à 15 et à 16 ans
aujourd'hui elle se marie plus tard
elles prennent le temps on a pris un
extrait c'est-à-dire on a pris dans
cette émission on voit qu'elle a 15 ans
ça arrive encore mais il y a pas
longtemps en France encore c'est arrivé
c'est à dire qu'en sachant que toute
notre vie vous les gitans on a été mis
de côté ça veut dire que en vérité on
est dans l'état là tu vois on arrive
gentiment
les mariages comme ça je pense
c'est c'était allongé qu'on se marier
tôt ça te dérange pas
peur de faire bouger les lignes Anissa
dans ce qu'elle dit
mais c'est vrai
ça veut dire qu'il te faut un truc ils
te mettent une voix le mec il va
chercher c'est un paquet de cigarettes
ou une connerie on dit surement avec
l'argent du crime
ça te dit la question c'est abusé c'est
pas une réalité ce qui se passe en
andalouse ça arrive alors bien sûr que
ça peut arriver mais c'est comme tout il
y a on a vu les mecs cabris bien sûr que
ça arrive mais c'est pas partout arrêtez
les gars on fait une généralité de tout
attends le peu de fois où ça arrive
écoutez si Sam vous savez chez nous
c'est alors c'est très rare le divorce
pas par obligation parce que c'est il y
a plein de divorce il y a ça arrive chez
nous aussi mais souvent les gens vous
savez quand vous savez c'est quoi quand
on courtise une fille vous savez souvent
on pose pas la question c'est des mois
et des mois de travail encore on a de la
fille où il se passe rien on se voit en
cachette c'est un petit bisou c'est des
trucs qui sont merveilleux c'est
romantique au possible et quand il se
marie bah il se marie pour de vrai
vous voyez ce que je veux dire ça veut
dire c'est vraiment démarrer de l'amour
et c'est
ça vous choque à 12 ans par exemple
qu'une jeune fille soit 12 ans
et l'une des traditions les plus
polémiques c'est la cérémonie du
mouchoir c'est un passage obligatoire
pour la mariée sa virginité est vérifiée
avec un mouchoir regardez c'est
l'extrait qui a fait le plus poli
la cérémonie du mouchoir une tradition
séculaire secrète la mariée sera ici
avec un mouchoir elle va prouver qu'elle
est vierge dès que les petites finesses
on les éduque ainsi elles peuvent donner
leur honneur
alors elles font attention elles ne
peuvent pas avoir de petits copains
alors mariage Cinéréa n'est pas vierge
elle fera la honte de sa famille et ne
pourra pas se marier les hommes eux
n'ont rien à prouver du tout ils
attendent dehors la vérification de
l'hymen ne dure que quelques minutes
néréa est maintenant officiellement
marié
ce mouchoir appartient maintenant à la
belle-mère de néréa
est-ce que ça ça vous choque oui et
c'est illégal il faut le rappeler en
France tout acte qui est tant à attester
de la virginité d'une personne a
fortiori mineur c'est un an de prison et
30000 euros d'amende donc ça c'est
illégal en français et moi ça me choque
parce que en fait c'est privé c'est une
jeune femme de son libre arbitre c'est à
dire qu'elle est promise vierge là c'est
presque je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais elle est presque forcé
d'être vierge elle n'est plus libre
d'elle-même
du mouchoirs ça arrive bien sûr ça
arrive encore ah ben non mais bon non
mais ça c'est vraiment ça c'est une
traditions
oui la plupart le vent mais ce que je
veux te dire c'est que elle est pas
forcément ça veut dire que elle est
obligée
elle peut choisir de pas voir le
mouchoir elle peut le choisir de dire
écoute moi je sais pas
la semaine dernière ils ont pas fait là
là on reste sur
pardon mais effectivement elle est
poussée par aussi toute la toute toute
la communauté qui dit que évidemment si
elle le refuse ce sera un souci parce
qu'il y aura forcément une suspicion et
donc là honte sur le reste de la famille
etc donc même si officiellement elle est
consentante fondamentalement elle est
elle se sent obligée contrainte de le
faire donc voilà donc ça pose problème
évidemment que ça pose problème vous
savez que ça a été imposé à Lady Di
avant le mariage
c'est dans la couronne la couronne
anglaise on a imposé à Lady Di lors du
mariage du prince Charles un certificat
de virginité elle a dû voir le le
gynécologue qui s'appelle docteur Pinker
je voulais être précis dans cette
histoire et il a prouvé donc elle était
vierge elle a pu épouser Charles
personne
alors ici parce que ici c'est illégal à
l'Assemblée nationale a voté le projet
de loi sur le séparatisme qui vise
notamment renforcer les mesures de
dignité humaine en interdisant les tests
de virginité et en s'assurant du
consentement des époux ils ont été plus
loin en interprétisant tout certificat
de virginité les médecins qui les
délivent être sanctionnés regardez on
arrive
prouver la virginité d'une femme sont
une violation des droits fondamentaux le
projet de loi contre les séparatisme va
permettre de les interdire et de
sanctionner les médecins qui les
rédigent d'une peine d'un an de prison
et 15000 euros d'amende il faut que la
France arrête ces gestes qui sont
humiliants pour les femmes qui ne sont
jamais demandé par elle qui sont
demandées par la famille c'est une
excellente mesure et le collège national
des gynécologues applaudit des deux
mains alors oui ça pourrait moi
j'imagine ça peut être considéré comme
une preuve d'amour de savoir que sa
future mariée s'est réservé pour son sur
le problème c'est qu'il y a pas le
problème c'est que c'est pas réciproque
c'est-à-dire que lui on lui demande pas
de virginité il a pu faire toutes les
conneries qui voulaient avant s'il le
veut et après c'est surtout le début
d'une série de de gestes machos où
l'homme est le roi absolu et la femme et
à son service
tout de suite en vérité ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui tu peux plus même plus
être viril mon ami non mais il y a pas
de légalité
à la maison c'est la femme qui fait à
manger qui fait la gueule
les amis on vit dans le même pays où moi
tu as laissé le finir là dessus il
travaille toute la journée il rentre sa
femme elle est restée et c'est un
travail de s'occuper des hommes vous
savez quoi si ma femme a voulu changer
le travail avec moi jamais de ma vie
elle a un travail de fou à la maison ma
femme mais j'en ai quatre c'est tombé le
dernier en plus psychopathe c'est
compliqué non non la vérité
mais ce que je veux dire chacun
chacun fait comme il veut bordel
aujourd'hui tu sais on dirait que tu as
plus le droit tu as plus le droit que ta
femme elle reste à la maison et que toi
tu vas travailler ou que elle va on
dirait que tout est jugé c'est pas
pareil le fait qu'elle mange une fois
que les hommes ont marqué les femmes
mangent une fois que les hommes ont
mangé elles mangent après c'est ça aussi
ça arrive ça arrive il y a des fois ça
arrive pas mais sauf que pardonnez-moi
mais le plus c'est pas du tout
couple si la seule envie de rester
d'élever les enfants j'ai pas à juger ça
en revanche effectivement le certificat
virginité le monsieur la responsable de
tous les gynécos en France disait que il
y avait une pression de la famille que
la femme la jeune fille quand elle
arrivait finalement il y a certaines
familles bien sûr et ça veut dire que
est-ce que si elle a envie de condamnez
vous à titre personnel
des fois où il y a pas de pression mais
bien sûr il y a des filles qui veulent
15 ans une fille peut si depuis toute
petite elle a été éduqué comme ça
comment elle peut avoir son libre
arbitre pour dire ben moi je vais être
vierge et c'est comme ça vous pensez pas
qu'elle est malgré tout sous pression et
sous emprise après je suis pas dans sa
tête je suis pas la tête des gens on
peut on n'est pas dans la tête des gens
mais en vérité vous savez quand c'est
une coutume c'est comme ça aujourd'hui
en France il y a plus de coutume
personne perd ses traditions il y a plus
aucune tradition des gens qui disent
pourquoi ils se mêlent des traditions
des autres il y a plein de gens qui
disent ça sur bien sûr alors
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça en
réalité illégalité Cyril à partir du
moment où il y a eu la loi il y a plein
de gens qui disent pourquoi de quoi il
se mêlent traditions mais qu'est-ce que
vous répondez alors je vais vous
répondre très franchement
chez les musulmans aussi il y a des
traditions qui parfois pèsent etc donc
je vous le dis très franchement
toi tu as des traditions qui te plaisent
oui c'est les musulmans il y a les
traditions et la Belgique
et la virginité peut être exigée aussi
c'était une tradition chez vous c'était
le déshonneur c'est une femme vous avez
une tradition chez vous c'est avant de
se marier une semaine avant vous faites
l'enterrement avant de vous promettre un
mariage pour la vie vous allez vous
frotter contre 10h vous continuez ça
c'est pas moi ça
veut dire ça peut me choquer aussi là tu
vas dire à ta femme tu vas te marier
pour toute la vie
mon frère on n'est pas des bonobos c'est
bon alors Géraldine tu disais un truc
non mais sauf que c'est pas mal
dans un pays il y a des lois alors on
fait des lois pour tous
sauf qu'il faut se soumettre aux lois de
notre pays
moi qui date depuis Napoléon il faut les
remettre au goût du jour
à protéger à protéger les femmes et les
hommes d'ailleurs
on a la chance d'avoir l'Aiglon ici
Daniel Moreau
moi je suis la première pourtant à
vouloir respecter les traditions mais là
d'abord c'est illégal et puis il y a
quand même un problème c'est que
évidemment je rappelle que c'est en
Espagne exactement
n'arrivent pas toujours vierge et
maintenant il y a quelque chose
malheureusement vous savez quoi les
temps ont changé et il y a quand même
quelque chose qui s'appelle le ducido
raccommodage c'est-à-dire de quoi en
fait c'est beaucoup plus drôle l'hymen
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on se retrouve
et il y a tout et comme ça coûte très
cher quelquefois elles font appel qui ne
sont pas et ça fait des infections et
tout ça donc c'est un problème ah ouais
et oui parce que les jeunes femmes
maintenant sont plus libérer qu'avant
mais avec le poids des traditions et
c'est un espèce de business dangereux il
y a des infections ça veut dire qu'on
veut tous sexualiser aujourd'hui il y a
le tout et son contraire ça veut dire
que on veut tous sexualiser aujourd'hui
ça veut dire on veut les sexualiser oh
oh à l'école primaire moi je vais vous
dire ma petite fille elle a 15 ans elle
regarde encore Blanche-Neige
vous savez moi une fille à 18 ans c'est
encore un bébé vous savez quoi son père
moi ma fille a 18 ans si elle avait un
téléphone
mais si elle en avait un je l'enlève son
téléphone elle va pleurer dans sa
chambre et quand elle va se marier c'est
un bébé encore même à 18 ans c'est un
bébé vous voyez ce que je veux dire
laissez les grandir laissez-les prendre
le temps aujourd'hui on dirait qu'à 14
ans il faut applaudir et je sais pas moi
qu'est-ce qu'on veut à nos enfants
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire de nos
enfants bordel et quand elle va se
marier vous imposerez un certificat de
virginité la tradition je pense qu'il va
le faire vous savez ce que moi je me dis
la vérité je vais vous dire la vérité va
le faire je voudrais lui faire un bon
mariage un mariage de princesse
mais quel père il va faire la cérémonie
du mouchoir non pas là parce qu'elle
veut en fait si elle décide de le faire
le frein mais je vais vous expliquer un
truc là
elle fera 18 ans après je sais pas je
vais vous dire moi ce que je veux moi je
veux pour ma vie qu'elle soit qu'elle
aime son mari je veux les plus belles
choses du monde ce qu'elle veut du
moment que c'est
qu'elle est heureuse bordel je peux être
plus alors je la protège je la protège
énormément parce que j'ai peur j'ai peur
vous savez qu'il y a combien de filles
si on faisait un sondage il y a combien
de filles qui ont couché avec quelqu'un
la première fois elles avaient même pas
envie elles l'ont fait parce que la
copine l'a fait ou parce que vous savez
c'est limite un viol à chaque fois c'est
à dire que la planète je vais vous
expliquer la liberté
s'il y a un consentement ça n'est ni un
bien sûr
des fois tu as pas envie de faire
quelque chose mais tu te sens obligé de
le faire tourner pas la chance parce que
effectivement il y a des jeunes femmes
qui peuvent après coup se dire à ma
première fois que tu es pas formidable
mais mais elle l'a souhaité oui on peut
pas le comparer à un viol parce que
c'est une instance
voilà peut-être que le mot était pas bon
viol mais ce que je veux dire laissez
les grandir bordel laissez les grands
laissez-les tranquille
pour une femme et pour un homme juste
préserver avant le mariage et là où il a
raison c'est que dans notre non mais
c'est vrai bah parce que on a grandi
dans une société où moi pendant qu'on
m'a pas dit que faire l'amour c'était
quelque chose de de d'important qu'il
faut pas faire avec n'importe qui etc et
moi je trouve ça beau après c'est vrai
que la cérémonie du mouchoir elle est
extrêmement violente et que la jeune
fille qu'on voit et il y a d'autres
portages qui l'ont fait aussi on a
l'impression qu'elles sont au bout de
leur vie parce que c'est devant des
dizaines de personnes et cetera donc
est-ce que ça peut pas on peut pas faire
évoluer la tradition pour que ce soit
une promesse morale et qui est pas c'est
en gros cette humiliation un peu dans
tout le monde avec des jeunes femmes pas
très contentes
de rien du tout en plus je vais vous
expliquer je parle comme moi d'ailleurs
quand vous la voyez pleurer là vous
croyez qu'elle pleure pas de souffrance
elle pleure parce qu'elle est émue elle
est vécu avec son papa et sa maman et au
même titre qu'une femme de 20 ans
qu'elle vous savez quand vous allez vous
marrer même chez vous je prends une
femme de même de 20 ans 25 ans et tout
dès que je regarde Daniel j'ai dit 22h
un ou deux ans après tu le sais
est-ce que je veux te dire c'est que
elle pleure aussi c'est des cours du
passé à Bali elle fait un bisou elle
pleure elle est émue vous alors tu vois
ça à la télé tu as l'impression qu'elle
souffre elle est heureuse d'être là elle
a fait grâce à toute sa famille elle a
décidé de dire jusqu'au il faut pas vous
l'intérêt je vois même pas pourquoi on
en parle aujourd'hui parce que c'est en
Espagne en plus
franchement
qu'est-ce qui peut arriver ce jour de
mariage si la jeune femme n'est pas
vierge justement c'est ce qui lui arrive
ah c'est ça moi j'ai jamais rien
franchement à ma connaissance Qu'est-ce
qui lui arrive
l'environnement la famille alors il y a
Lissac à sa petite idée je pense qu'elle
va être une idée de sa famille tout
simplement parce que c'est ça
veut dire mon fils il fume de la drogue
je le renie ma famille alors je
l'engueule je suis pas content
le reportage en tout cas on explique
effectivement il y a une dame qui dit si
effectivement elle ne elle ne devait pas
être vierge ce serait la honte sur la
famille on imagine les conséquences
ça te choque ça non ça me jette pas mais
elle veut divertir toute la famille
comment tu le prouves non mais c'est moi
je le vois tout de suite
le garçon peut dire voilà moi aussi
c'est la première fois sans vérifier
la virginité d'un garçon parce que les
femmes sont très importantes chez nous
contrairement à tout ce qu'on peut
penser la femme bien sûr et que vous
voulez que ce qu'on lui impose un
mariage à 11 ans à 12 ans à 15 ans
voilà on en serait pas là mais c'est pas
parce que je suis d'accord avec lui un
reportage ça fait dire ce que tu veux
avec un truc donc voilà donc merci donc
je vais te dire avec un reportage tu
fais dire n'importe quoi avec un
reportage je peux dire que Bernard
Montiel à trois couilles merci alors il
faut ensuite la fête jusqu'à très tard
ils sont vraiment une photo jusqu'à
s'installer ensemble regardez
en signe de respect son père et son
grand-père laillent sur leur dos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est près de 5 heures du matin
néréa peut enfin souffler
[Applaudissements]
par les hommes pour la virginité de sa
femme
on sera toujours ensemble c'est comme ça
chez nous
plus qu'ailleurs les règles sont
strictes le divorce est interdit dès la
fin de la cérémonie le couple s'instadra
dans un appartement dans le quartier de
leur enfance
les divans interdits ils ont dit mais
pareil c'est la voix off mais vous
l'écoutez
pas venu
vérifier
on prend un hangar et moi je dis au mec
de caméraman mais je veux pas qu'on t'a
vu je suis un peu connu je veux pas que
on puisse vérifier enfin si tu es le
lieu de là où il est le mandat vous
savez ce qu'il a dit la BOF ils ont
ouvert un hangar vérifié ils ont ouvert
en garde comme ça comme si on avait
ouvert un an gardant la oui il y a
l'état bien le chien du courant il y a
tout comme si on avait exploité un truc
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit mais ils
ont dit qu'on avait squatté un truc non
alors que c'est le garage mon cousin on
voulait juste à savoir où il était non
tu comprends ce que ça dure
ça simplement
merci de participer à l'émission vous
vous honorez votre
cachets
non à 33 %